Mein Name ist Gecer, ich bin hier auf der Station der Diensthabende Arzt und ich bin zuständig für Sie.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, danach können wir über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Linus Müller.
Linus Müller.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Linus ist ganz einfach, L-I-N-U-S und der Familie Name ist Müller, M-U-Umlaut, doppel-L-E-R.
Okay, Herr Müller. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 29.
29. Wann sind Sie gerne aufgeboren?
Am 27. April, 96.
96.
27. April, richtig?
Ja.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 181.
181.
Okay. 181.
181. Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ja, ich wiege so 78 kg.
78 kg. Okay.
Herr Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe ganz schlimme Bauchschmerzen.
Und zwar bin ich heute Morgen mit meinem E-Bike vom Dienst nach Hause gefahren.
Ich hatte eine Nachtschicht und als ich nach Hause gefahren bin,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich nicht gut aufgepasst habe,
aber irgendwie bin ich gegen Bordstein gekommen und bin richtig auf die linke Seite geknallt.
Und ich hatte ordentlich Geschwindigkeit drauf.
Und ich hatte zwar ein Helm auf, aber irgendwie habe ich mir hier so die Seite und den Bauch geprellt.
Und da hatte ich ganz schlimme Schmerzen zunächst.
Und das ist aber dann eigentlich besser geworden.
Ich bin dann nach Hause, habe mein Fahrrad ein Stück geschoben, das letzte Stück,
das war nicht mehr weit.
Und dann habe ich mich hingelegt.
Und dann hatte ich das Gefühl, die Schmerzen werden auch besser.
Aber dann habe ich ein bisschen geschlafen.
Und dann bin ich aufgewacht und mit einmal waren die Schmerzen so schlimm.
Und jetzt sind sie auch immer noch ganz heftig.
Also, ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann zum Teil wirklich kaum Luft kriegen.
Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass mein Herz ganz schnell schlägt.
Ich bin richtig ein bisschen zitterig.
Und dann hat mich meine Partnerin, hat gesagt, ich bringe schnell in die Klinik.
Und dann haben wir hier auch eine Aufnahme gleich gesagt, dass es mir gar nicht gut geht.
Sind Ihnen schwarz vor den Augen?
Nee, schwarz vor Augen ist mir jetzt nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Oder waren Sie bewusstlos?
Ich war glaubt, nee, ich war nicht bewusstlos.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Auf der linken Seite, ja, so unter den Rippen oder hinter den Rippen.
Und Flanke auch, leiden Sie unter Flanke.
Ja, so an der Seite tut es halt weh.
Und es sind solche Schmerzen.
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzintensität bewerten?
Auf einer Schmerzschikada von 1 bis 10.
Vorbei 1 ist geringste, 10 ist schlimmste.
Also am Anfang, als ich gefallen bin,
hat er es nicht so doll wehge.
Also, da hat es schon auch weh getan, aber ist dann ja besser geworden.
Aber jetzt würde ich schon sagen, das ist zwischen 8 und 9, würde ich sagen.
Also da ist es bestimmt.
Das ist nicht so ganz für Schmerzen.
Ja, ich muss unsere Gespräche jetzt unterbrechen.
Ich werde Sie zuerst Körperlücken untersuchen
und danach Blut abnehmen.
Und dann würde ich Ihre vitalen Parameter messen.
Ich würde eine venösen Zugang legen und ich gebe Ihnen Schmerzmittel.
Das ist gut, ja.
Aber Sie allergieren gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Das Einzige, was ich weiß, dass ich keinen Amoxicillin vertraue.
Das habe ich mal gehabt.
Aber das ist so eine Unvertretlichkeit.
Das wird ja nicht jetzt ein entscheidenden Laktose,
kann ich nicht gut vertragen.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie genau.
Legen Sie sich hin bitte jetzt.
Ich werde ein paar Masken durchführen, Ihre Vitalparameter messen.
Und ja, können wir jetzt weiter machen, oder?
Okay, ja.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Ihre Schmerzen dumm oder stehend?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, die sind dumm.
Das trifft es am ehesten, ja.
Sag ich so ganz stark, Druck habe, ja.
Dumm Schmerzen, okay.
Sind Ihnen über?
Ja, also jetzt ist mich vor dem Schmerz verschmerzt, ja.
Okay, Sie haben Überkeit?
Haben Sie sich übergeben, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist nur jetzt so von den Schmerzen, dass ich das Gefühl habe,
dass die so...
Sie strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus in die linke Schulter,
oder strahlen Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, also, muss ich sagen, ja, doch.
Also das ist hier so an der linken Seite.
Und dann geht das so bis hoch in den Schulterbereich, ja.
Okay, und auch in den Rücken, strahlen Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, so ein bisschen in den Rücken, ja.
In den Rücken und in die linke Schulter, okay.
Okay.
Hermüner, haben Sie Fieber oder Schüterlfrust?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie sittern, gestitert hat.
Ja, also, aber, nee, also keinen Schüttelfrust,
und ich fühle mich auch nicht fieberig.
Nicht fieberig.
Okay.
Wegen Schmerzen haben Sie gesitert, oder?
Ja, ja.
Oder haben Sie kaltschweiß, kaltschweiß, oder?
Ja, eigentlich, also mehr so, dass ich so aufgeregt war, ja,
dass ich mir dann Angst hatte.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe Sie genau.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, bitte.
Ich bin für Sie da, und wir sind hier erfahrene Klinik,
deswegen machen wir unsere Bestes für Sie.
Ja, Sie haben auch Überkeit, und haben Sie keine Beustuf gehabt.
Beustuf war ich nicht, ich meine, ich habe alles mitgekriegt.
Und andere Körperregionen, auch Schmerzen,
beispielsweise im linken Arm oder linken Oberschenkel,
Unterschenkel, oder?
Ja, also ich glaube, ich habe da schon ein paar blaue Flecken,
da, wo ich drauf geknallt bin.
Aber das ist so vergleichsweise nichts im Vergleich zu dem,
zu diesem Bauchschmerzen nach.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter auch Atemnot, richtig?
Atemnot, nicht wirklich, nein.
Okay, nicht.
Haben Sie auch Herzrasen, Herzstörungen?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich ganz dolles Herzklopfen habe,
ja, zwischendurch, ja.
Okay, Herzklopfen.
Okay, fühlen Sie Taubachsgefühl in den Oberarm oder Unterarm,
oder in den Finger, oder?
Ne, das fühlt sich alles normal an.
Ja, Sie fühlen Sie, und können Sie Ihre Oberarm und Füße genau bewegen?
Haben Sie Bewegung?
Ja, also das tut natürlich jetzt ein bisschen weh,
dass ich draufgefallen bin, aber ich kann das grundsätzlich schon bewegen, ja.
Okay, Sie können bewegen und Sie können auch laufen
und Sie können belasten, richtig?
Ja, also beim Laufen hat es jetzt so weh getan,
dass ich wirklich also kaum gehen konnte,
aber das hat nicht am Bein gelegen, ne?
Okay, okay, Herr Müller, ich verstehe.
Hatten Sie auch Kopfverletzung gehabt?
Zum Glück habe ich ein Helm, ja, immer auf, ja,
das hat wohl einiges abgefangen, ja.
Okay, Kopfverletzung nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Sechstörung oder Höchststörung?
Nein, ich denke, ich kann gut sehen und hören.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Herr Müller, ja, ich möchte über Ihre Vorerkrankungen sprechen jetzt.
Leiden Sie an chronischen oder erdlichen Erkrankungen, ja?
Ja, also, was ich tatsächlich habe seit der Kindheit,
das ist Neurodermitis, dass ich, also hier hinter den Ohren
habe ich so eine Stelle und an den Armen, in den Armbeugen
und in den Kniekehlen, dass ich da so ein bisschen
juckenden und schuppigen Ausschlag habe, da muss ich hin und wieder
mal Medikamente nehmen und ja, also, was ich auch habe,
das ist blöd bei meinem Schichtdienst, ich habe hin und wieder
migraine Attacken und vielleicht so, ja, das hat vor 2, 3 Jahren
angefangen und ja, das erwischt mich so ein, 2 Mal im Monat
und dann bin ich schon auch richtig gehandicapt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Neurodermitis, nehmen Sie oder tragen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Ich habe da eine Salbe, die ich da auftragen kann.
Ja, kennen Sie die Namen oder?
Aha, nein, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie das heißt,
aber ich weiß, das ist so eine Cortison-haltige Salbe.
Und gegen Migraine, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, also, was mir eigentlich am besten hilft, ist, wenn ich sofort,
wenn ich das merke, dass es losgeht, dass ich Aspirin nehme,
dann komme ich eigentlich ganz gut zurecht, ja.
Ja, kennen Sie Dosierung und eine Mauer?
Ja, 500, 500, da muss ich mindestens haben
und manchmal muss ich da noch eine zweite hinterher nehmen, ne?
Okay, bei Bedarf nehmen Sie.
Ja, die nehme ich natürlich nicht regelmäßig, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe genau.
Wurde da Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, und zwar, ja, da bin ich auch mit dem Fahrrad hingefallen,
das ist, aber schon 5 Jahre her, da bin ich,
da bin ich auf den rechten Arm gefallen
und das musste operiert werden
und da hatte ich auch am Kopf einen Platzwunden.
Ja, Oberarm gebrochen, richtig, habe ich richtig verstanden,
okay, und vor fünf Jahren wurde sie operiert.
Ja, also eigentlich war da hauptsächlich diese Platzwunde am Kopf
und der Oberarm musste halt gerichtet werden, ne?
Okay, Kopfverletzung und Oberarmfraktur, okay.
Und sonst noch, hatten Sie andere Operationen, oder?
Nee, sonst bin ich nicht operiert worden.
Okay, alles gut.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie am Amoxicirin allergie,
haben Sie auch andere Allergen, oder?
Um Verträglichkeiten, auch Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie an Laktorintoleranz...
Ja, also da kriege ich ziemlich schnell so heftige Blähungen
und Durchfälle und so, und wenn ich das weglasse,
geht es mir eigentlich besser, ja.
Okay, Laktorintoleranz.
Und wie äußert sich Amoxicirin mit Yuken, oder?
Ja, da kriege ich Ausschlag, ja.
Okay, Ausschlag.
Okay.
Herr Müller, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe auch tatsächlich eine Tetanusimpfung
und gegen Covid bin ich auch geimpft worden, ja.
Wann hatten Sie letzte Tetanusimpfung gehabt?
Oh, das ist noch nicht so lange her.
Sie haben vor fünf Jahren.
Das war bei dem letzten, weil ich es sich mit den Armen gebrochen habe, ja.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Okay, das freut mich.
Herr Müller, rauchen Sie?
Nein, seit ein paar Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe aber auch nie so heftig geraucht.
Ich habe sechs Jahre lang mal,
ich habe so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag geraucht,
aber wirklich nie so richtig viel.
Und dann habe ich mir das jetzt wieder abgewöhnt
und seit vier Jahren rauche ich gar nicht mehr.
Seit vier Jahren?
Sie rauchen nicht.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Das freut mich.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke abends mal ein Bier oder ein Glas Wein,
wenn ich zu Hause, wenn ich nicht arbeiten muss, ne?
Okay.
Ein Flasche Bier oder ein oder zwei Glas Wein, richtig?
Ein Glas Wein, ja, also mehr eigentlich nicht.
Und ja, jetzt im Sommer gerne meine Flasche Bier,
wenn es warm ist und wenn man lustig ist, ja.
Okay, okay.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht, bitte.
Fragen wir aufgrund medizinischen Gründen immer.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen oder haben Sie Cannabis oder Drogen
eingenommen oder geraucht?
Nein, nein, nein, da habe ich nie irgendwas gemacht.
Das ist sehr gut, ja.
Ist in Ihrer Familie, sind in Ihrer Familie chronisch
oder ärztliche Erkrankungen bekannt, zum Beispiel
Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder Krebsarten?
Ja, also mein Vater hat Darmkrebs,
das hat man vor zwei Jahren festgestellt
und der ist operiert worden und hat auch
eine Chemo-Bekomm, Chemotherapie bekommen.
Dem geht jetzt eigentlich so, weil es ganz leidlich.
Es gibt mir da eine Idee.
Ja, und ich habe ein Zwillingsbruder,
der hat Asthma schon als Kind auch gehabt.
Und Ihre Mutter, Karimula?
Ja, also die Mutter, die hat auch nicht so richtig,
die hat jetzt nicht irgendwie so Kreislauferkrankungen
oder so etwas, die hat es mit der Hüfte.
Die hat ein neues Hüftgelenk und das andere steht an.
Ja, Vater leidet an Darmkrebs oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay, Darmkrebs.
Haben Sie andere Geschwester außer Ihre Zwillingeburden?
Nein, wir sind nur zu zweit gewesen.
Okay, Sie sind nur zu zweit.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Karimula?
Ja, ich bin Zugbegleiter bei der Deutschen Bahn.
Zugbegleiter.
Ja, und deswegen habe ich halt auch oft unregelmäßige Arbeitszeiten
und das macht sich schon ein bisschen bemerkbar in meinem,
ja ich schlafe zum Beispiel nicht gut oder so, ne?
Ja, Sie haben Stress.
Ja, das ist schon aufregend, ja.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich habe leider schon geschieden, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, unsere kleine Tochter, die lebt aber bei meiner geschiedenen Frau.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich habe einige Fragen auch.
Ich würde gerne stellen.
Leiden Sie unter Durchfall oder Verstoffung?
Ja, wenn ich mich an meine Diät halte, dann geht es mir gut.
Aber wenn ich natürlich irgendwie dann doch mal was mit Milch zu fassen kriege,
dann merke ich das schon schnell.
Dann habe ich mit Durchfall zu tun.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Wasserlässeprobleme?
Nein, das würde los nicht, ja.
Oder heute haben Sie Blutbeimischung bei Wasserlässe oder beim Sturrgang bemerkt?
Nein, es ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber da habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht drauf geguckt.
Okay, Sie haben nicht bemerkt.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt
und ich habe keine weitere Fragen.
Ich möchte Sie jetzt nochmal untersuchen.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Natürlich habe ich Fragen, die es jetzt weitergeht.
Aber das können Sie erst sagen, wenn Sie weitere Untersuchungen gemacht haben.
Ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch zusätzlich an Informationen geben kann.
Ja, es hängt von der Ergebnisse ab.
Wenn die Ergebnisse vorliegen, ich würde Sie darüber informieren.
Aber muss es sich denn im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, mit dem Ergebnis werde ich Sie genauer informieren.
Jetzt werde ich ein paar bildgebende Verfahren durchführen.
Bauch, Ultraschall werde ich durchführen.
Und Torax-Röntgen, Lungen-Röntgen werde ich auch durchführen.
Bauch-Röntgen.
Und gegenebenfalls werde ich ein CT des Baus durchführen.
Und dann die Ergebnisse vorliegen mit der Blutergebnisse auch.
Und dann werde ich Sie darüber informieren.
Okay, gut.
Bleiben Sie hier bitte und ja.
Gut.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Trauma, Patients, immer stressig.
Bitte was?
Trauma, Patientin oder Patient sind immer stressig.
Ja, aber Sie haben das hier super gemacht, dass Sie gleich gesagt haben,
wir unterbrechen nicht, untersuch Sie jetzt erst.
Das war ja schon mal super, ja.
Ja, ich bin Traumatoloch, deswegen.
Natürlich.
Deswegen, das ist eine sehr eine Situation.
Mitstruktur oder intraabdominal Blutung sind sehr wichtig.
Das ist ja auch eine sehr typische Situation.
Man würde ja wahrscheinlich gleich weiter untersuchen.
Und würde auch nicht diese ganzen Fragen jetzt noch mal in aller Ruhe stellen,
sondern man würde die ja wahrscheinlich während man weiter untersucht.
Normalerweise, wir untersuchen,
andererseits Fragrum, ja, normalerweise.
Ja, eben, genau.
Aber es geht halt nicht so, ja.
Ein bisschen künftig ist unsere Situation natürlich.
Gut.
Jetzt die Frage, ob irgendjemand von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
noch zusätzliche Fragen hat.
Ich bereite es zwei Minuten vor.
Alles abgefragt, ne?
Eine Kollege hat geschrieben,
auf dem Imdentjet, ich glaube, sie meine, oder er meine,
haben sie, hatten sie für irgendwelche abnormale Gefühle vorher gestürzt.
Ach, bevor ich gefallen bin.
Also praktisch als Ursache für den Sturz.
Ja, gibt es eine, die...
Nein, ich bin nur zu schnell gefahren und war vielleicht ein bisschen müde
und bin gegen Wortschrank geknallt, ne?
Mit meinem super schnellen E-Bike.
Haben Sie Husten?
Ne.
Aber ich glaube, Husten würde auch weh tun jetzt.
Mach mal irgendwie ganz schnell meinen Film.
Guten Abend, Frau Obererstin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja.
Ich berichte über den 29-jährigen Patienten,
Herrn Linas Müller, der 1,81 Meter groß ist
und 78 Kilogramm miet.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns wegen linksseitiger epigastrischer Schmerzen
vor Mit Ausstrahlung in die Linkenschule und in den Rücken.
Außerdem klagte der Patient über,
ob der Husten bei uns von hier zu kommen,
Was ist denn passiert?
Der Patient hat mit dem Fahrrad aufgefallen.
Heute Morgen ist der Patient mit dem Fahrrad aufgefallen.
Dann hat er aufgefallen.
Gestürzt?
Ja gestürzt.
Gestürzt.
Hingefallen.
Okay, ja.
Ja, gestürzt.
Hingefallen.
Nach dem Unfall hat er sehr stark Epigastrische schmerzen.
Nach dem Unfall hat er nach Hause gegangen.
Nach dem Unfall hat sich die Schmerzen verhindert.
Nach dem Unfall hat sich die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Haben sie verschlechtert, okay?
Ja, verschlechtert.
Und Fragen nach Fiba oder Kaltschweiß, Schwarz von Augern,
Sehstörungen, Höhrstörungen oder Lehmung, Taubeizgefühl wurden vermeint.
Beim Bewegung und beim Atmen hat sich die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Haben die Schmerzen verschlechtert?
Haben die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Der Patient leidet seit zwei Jahren Neurodermitis.
Jetzt müssen Sie erst mal, haben Sie den Patienten jetzt notfallmäßig untersucht?
Ja, ich habe der Patient natürlich notfallmäßig untersucht.
Zuerst habe ich Vitalparameter gemessen und hatte einen Zugang geleckt.
Ich habe auf der anderen Seite die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Ich habe die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Wenn der Patient stabil war, habe ich unsere Aufnahmegespräch durchgeführt.
Der Patient leidet seit zwei Jahren Neurodermitis.
Er leidet seit drei Jahren Migren.
Er leidet seit zwei Jahren Migren.
Bei den Patienten wurde ein Humerusfraktur durchgeführt.
Der Patient hatte eine Allergie gegen Amoxicin, die mit Exantem und Pruritis äußert.
Der Patient hat auch Laktosintoleranz.
Er ist vorstandengeimpft.
Er ist vor fünf Jahren nicht rauchig.
Er hat vor vier Jahren aufgehört.
Aber er hat sechs Jahre Halbschaft der Zigarette geraucht.
Er hat drei Paketjahre Zigarette erfunden.
Er trinkt selten Alkohol oder ein Glas Wein oder ein Fleisch Bier.
Er hat einen Darmkrebs erlitten.
Er hat eine Kolonkarsin.
Er hat eine Chemotherapie erlitten.
Er leidet an Herzerkrankung oder Herzkreislauferkrankung.
Er leidet an Asthma-Bronchiale.
Er leidet an Aramnestischen Angaben.
Er leidet an Intraabdominalblutung oder Pancreas-Verletzung.
Er leidet an Pynomotorax.
Er leidet an Lipenfraktur.
Er leidet an Körperlöschen.
Er leidet an Abwärtsspannung.
Er leidet an Aspektär.
Er leidet an Hermatome.
Er leidet an Blasau.
Er leidet an Herzklopfen.
Er leidet an Blutblut.
Er leidet an INR-Koagulation-Parameters.
Er leidet ein Bildgeber.